oh
[Music]
a 13 year old from poland wows the
judges on america's got talent and simon
cowell makes her small town dreams come
true sarah sarah
we've heard a lot of singers over the
years but wow there's no denying sarah
james has some real star potential
during season 17 auditions the young
singer takes the stage to audition with
an emotional billy eilish cover
[Music]
and let's just say it was a lovely
rendition of the pop star's hit song
[Music]
hello
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
before giving it her best shot sarah
admits she was nervous to sing
especially in front of simon i feel
inside that i'm gonna i don't know pee i
just i'm just so nervous
i hope someone's gonna gonna be
impressed and he's gonna like it safe to
say sarah made quite the impression on
the whole crowd receiving a standing
ovation from judges heidi klum sofia
vergara howie mandel and even simon i
mean just takes my breath away simon was
the first to give his honest feedback
after sarah's moving performance this
wasn't
perfect
however you have a real star
glow about you thank you so much wow
thank you appreciate it is this your
first time to america yeah that's true
but sarah definitely didn't see this
coming i can remember when i came to
america for the first time and that was
20 odd years ago
and that was the moment i'll never
forget
and i want to make this a moment for you
to remember forever
yep simon smashing the golden buzzer
sending sarah straight to the live shows
so grateful and
literally the hovers thank you so much
sarah's golden buzzer marks the second
we've seen this season the first howie
mendel's pick a fellow young singer
maddie taylor bias
[Music]
how
[Music]
howie was so impressed he had to give
maddie the honor and when e.t caught up
with the comedian in may he couldn't
stop raving about the talent this season
give me three words to describe the
season what would you what would you
three words that just describe what the
audience has in store this year exciting
exciting exciting this year
i mean it is off the hook people
it's not normal people are thinking like
outside the box they really are
nothing seems normal
[Music]